This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a common complaint that people don't read books anymore. But the truth is print book sales are up these days. Since 2013, sales of physical books have increased every year. At first people attributed this to the rise of adult coloring books, but even as their popularity has dwindled, book sales have risen. I'm talking about physical, old-fashioned books with paper pages full of words. We love them. The great Argentinian writer Jorge Luis Borges once said,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。人们常抱怨现在没人读书了，但事实是，如今纸质书的销量其实在上升。自2013年以来，实体书销量每年都在增长。起初，人们将其归因于成人涂色书的兴起，但即便这类书的热度已减退，图书销量依然在上涨。我指的是那种有纸质书页、写满文字的、老派的实体书。我们热爱它们。伟大的阿根廷作家豪尔赫·路易斯·博尔赫斯曾说：
I cannot sleep unless I am surrounded by books. And I kind of agree. That's reporter Pierce Gully, although he's not normally a reporter. I'm a graduate student in creative writing, and for the past two years, I've taught fiction writing to undergrads at the University of Virginia. I assign a lot of reading, but mostly it's in the form of photocopied pages. Don't worry, the print shop pays for the rights. I don't want to force my students to buy too much, but I always make sure I assign at least one physical book.
“如果身边没有书，我就无法入睡。”我对此深有同感。说话的是记者皮尔斯·格利，尽管他平时并不是记者。“我是创意写作专业的研究生，过去两年里，我一直在弗吉尼亚大学教本科生写小说。我布置了很多阅读任务，但大多是复印件。别担心，印刷店支付了版权费。我不想强迫学生买太多书，但我总是确保至少布置一本实体书。”
And I always try to pick something that's beautiful, one with a nice font, a lovely page design, a pleasing paper grain, and an intriguing cover. Don't get me wrong, the words inside matter too. But I think it's important for my students to have an object that accentuates the pleasure of the physical act of reading, and something they would hold on to after the class had ended. I personally toss hundreds of pages of radio scripts in the recycling bin every month, but I would have a really hard time throwing away a book. Once the pages have a spine, it's like they have a soul. It would feel wrong, like you're spitting on knowledge itself.
“我总是尽量挑选那些精美的书，比如字体优美、版式精良、纸张质感舒适、封面引人入胜的书。别误会，书里的内容也很重要。但我认为，让学生拥有一件能提升阅读这种物理行为乐趣的物品，并且在课程结束后他们仍愿意珍藏，这很重要。我个人每个月都会把数百页的广播稿扔进回收箱，但我很难扔掉一本书。一旦书页装订成册，它们就仿佛有了灵魂。扔掉它们会让我觉得不对劲，就像是在亵渎知识本身。”
It's so hard to get rid of books. This is a story about books, and brace yourself how to get rid of them. And in the words of REM, it starts with an earthquake. It was the most Bay Area sporting event imaginable. The Oakland A's were playing the San Francisco Giants in the 1989 World Series. Coming into the third game on October 17th, 1989, the A's were in the lead. They had won the first two games.
扔掉书是件很难的事。这是一个关于书的故事，请做好心理准备，我们要讲讲如何处理它们。用REM乐队的话说，这始于一场地震。那是湾区最典型的体育赛事。1989年世界大赛，奥克兰运动家队对阵旧金山巨人队。在1989年10月17日的第三场比赛开始前，运动家队处于领先地位。他们已经赢下了前两场。
Allowing Jose con Seiko to score, and he fails to get Dave Parker. But just as the third game was about to kick off, take it. Take it. I'll tell you what, we have it in the room. The TV broadcast cut out. The third game was about to kick off. The TV broadcast cut out. When the signal came back, it was no longer a baseball game.
让何塞·坎塞科得分，但他没能接住戴夫·帕克的球。但就在第三场比赛即将开始时，拿走它。拿走它。我告诉你，我们在房间里收到了信号。电视转播中断了。第三场比赛即将开始。电视转播中断了。当信号恢复时，那已经不再是一场棒球比赛了。
These were the early minutes of the Loma Prieta earthquake, which struck near Santa Cruz. This was the first major earthquake ever to be broadcast live on National TV. We have a report of a person trapped in an elevator in Shelter Bay. Part of the Bay Bridge had been destroyed. There were fires, fallen buildings, widespread power outages. In all, there were 63 deaths and almost 4,000 injuries. But this is a story about what happened to the San Francisco Public Library after this earthquake and because of this earthquake.
这是洛马普里塔地震发生的最初几分钟，震中位于圣克鲁斯附近。这是有史以来第一次在国家电视台上直播的大地震。我们收到报告称有人被困在谢尔特湾的一部电梯里。海湾大桥的一部分已经损毁。到处是火灾、倒塌的建筑和大规模停电。总共有63人死亡，近4000人受伤。但这是一个关于地震发生后，旧金山公共图书馆经历了什么，以及因为这场地震发生了什么的故事。
The library suffered a lot of damage, especially on the higher floors. So one of the things about an earthquake is the effect of it is intensify the higher floors. On the upper levels of the library, floors had caved in. Jason Gibbs was a new librarian there, but he couldn't go to work for two months after the quake. It was too dangerous. He says bookshelves had collapsed sideways or fallen on their faces, and books lay in piles everywhere. Like the books had been tossed around by some angry force.
图书馆遭受了严重破坏，尤其是高层。地震的一个特点是高层受到的影响会加剧。在图书馆的上层，楼板已经坍塌。杰森·吉布斯当时是那里的一名新馆员，但地震后他有两个月无法上班。太危险了。他说书架侧向倒塌或正面着地，书堆到处都是。就像书被某种愤怒的力量随意抛掷过一样。
No one was injured at the San Francisco Public Library, but the earthquake dumped half a million books on the floor. Even after two months of repairs, the post-earthquake situation in the San Francisco Public Library was still pretty bad, library management determined that the stacks weren't safe and designated a new room for public browsing. Librarians curated a selection of books that they thought the public would most like to
旧金山公共图书馆没有人受伤，但地震将五十万本书震落到了地上。即使经过两个月的维修，旧金山公共图书馆震后的情况依然很糟糕，图书馆管理层认定书库不再安全，并指定了一个新的房间供公众浏览。馆员们精心挑选了一批他们认为公众最想
read, and those books went in that room. But they realized along the way that not every book was going to fit. In other words, even this windowed down selection of books was too large for the available space. They needed to window it down even more. The earthquake should happen. We don't have this shelving anymore. We need to make space. That's a reasonable thing to do if you approach it in a thoughtful way. Because libraries do get rid of books. All the time, earthquake or not. Put simply, there are so many new books coming in every day, and only a finite amount of library space.
阅读的书籍，并将它们放入那个房间。但他们在此过程中意识到，并不是每一本书都能放得下。换句话说，即使是这批精选的书籍，对于现有空间来说也太大了。他们需要进一步精简。“地震发生了。我们没有这些书架了。我们需要腾出空间。”如果你以深思熟虑的方式处理，这确实是合理的做法。因为图书馆一直在清理书籍，无论是否发生地震。简单来说，每天都有大量新书入库，而图书馆的空间是有限的。
The practice of freeing up library space is called Weeding. If you think about it, it sounds ugly, but it is a really good description. That's Sharon McKellor, she supervises teen services at the Oakland Public Library. A bridge up and went down the street to visit her and see how she weeds. You have to weed your garden for like the flowers to grow. I'm not a gardener. And weeding is not just about holding the book in your hands and asking yourself if that book sparks joy.
这种腾出图书馆空间的做法被称为“剔旧”（Weeding）。如果你仔细想想，这个词听起来不太好听，但它确实是一个非常贴切的描述。说话的是莎伦·麦凯勒，她是奥克兰公共图书馆青少年服务部的负责人。我过桥去拜访她，看看她是如何进行剔旧的。“你必须修剪花园，花儿才能生长。”我不是园丁。而且剔旧不仅仅是拿着书问自己这本书是否能带来快乐。
But there's really, really specific guidelines. We're not just random like grabbing books off the shelf and putting them in the trash. The color and many other librarians that libraries all over the world weed their shelves using the same set of guidelines. And it has an excellent acronym. Musty. M-U-S-T-Y. M is for misleading.
“其实有非常、非常具体的指导方针。我们不是随机从书架上抓书扔进垃圾桶。”麦凯勒和世界各地许多其他图书馆员一样，使用同一套指导方针来清理书架。它有一个很棒的缩写：MUSTY（发霉）。M-U-S-T-Y。M代表误导（Misleading）。
Or factually inaccurate. You is for ugly. This one's a little ugly. It's like the cover is a little broken. It isn't the fact that it's so beat up and indication that it was loved. For sure. So if it's been checked out in the last three years, I'd probably actually buy a new copy of it.
或者事实不准确。U代表丑陋（Ugly）。“这一本有点丑。封面有点破损。”书破旧不堪难道不是它曾被深爱的证明吗？当然是。所以如果它在过去三年里被借阅过，我可能会买一本新的来替换。
If it hasn't been checked out in the last three years, I would probably consider it for withdrawal. S for Super Seated. Buy a new edition or a much better book. This would be like an old manual for Windows 98 or an outdated travel guide. These are the kinds of books that get shredded. And the last two letters are T for trivial and Y for your collection has no use for this book,
如果它在过去三年里没有被借阅过，我可能会考虑将其撤架。S代表被取代（Superceded）。购买新版本或更好的书。这就像是一本旧的Windows 98手册或过时的旅游指南。这些书会被粉碎。最后两个字母是T代表琐碎（Trivial），Y代表你的馆藏不再需要这本书（Your collection has no use for this book）。
because they really want that musty acronym to work. Those last two, the T and the Y, trivial and your library has no need for this book, these are the tricky ones. They're not necessarily statements of fact, they're judgments of value. What's trivial to me might be very important to you and vice versa. But even here, these judgment calls are made by librarians who specialize in the relevant section based on circulation statistics. You just have to trust that your librarians are doing their best for the public. We want to be able to keep bringing you the most relevant, most current information,
因为他们真的很想让MUSTY这个缩写成立。最后两个，T和Y，琐碎和你的图书馆不再需要这本书，这些是比较棘手的。它们不一定是事实陈述，而是价值判断。对我来说琐碎的东西，对你来说可能非常重要，反之亦然。但即便如此，这些判断也是由负责相关部门的馆员根据流通统计数据做出的。你只需要相信你的馆员正在为公众尽最大努力。我们希望能够持续为你提供最相关、最新的信息，
and the only way to do that is by having room to do it. So the only way we can do that is by sometimes withdrawing the things that are not as useful anymore. All the sum sections according to the library guidelines are generally self-weeding. In other words, they disappear. Oh, people steal them. Yeah, certain sections of the library tend to disappear more than others. Books about marijuana, the Bible, and the calls are probably the biggest ones I can think of. But for the sections that do have to get weated, weeding is generally a touchy subject. The reason why is probably already clear to you.
而做到这一点的唯一方法就是有空间。所以我们能做的唯一方法就是有时撤下那些不再那么有用的东西。根据图书馆的指导方针，某些部分通常是“自动剔旧”的。换句话说，它们消失了。“哦，人们偷走了它们。”是的，图书馆的某些部分往往比其他部分更容易消失。关于大麻、圣经和塔罗牌的书可能是我能想到的流失最严重的几类。但对于那些确实需要剔旧的部分，剔旧通常是一个敏感的话题。原因你可能已经很清楚了。
People don't like the idea of books being thrown away. We like books a lot, and perhaps no one loves books more than librarians. There's a part of you that just winces every time you have to remove a book. I mean, your books are dear to us. Part of my maturing as a librarian is to get over that a little bit. Yes, weeding is normal and necessary. But after the 1989 earthquake, the San Francisco Public Library started weeding an unusual amount of books.
人们不喜欢扔书的想法。我们非常喜欢书，也许没有人比图书馆员更爱书了。你内心深处总会因为不得不移除一本书而感到难受。我的意思是，书对我们来说很珍贵。作为一名图书馆员，我成熟的一部分就是克服这一点。是的，剔旧是正常且必要的。但在1989年地震后，旧金山公共图书馆开始剔除数量异常庞大的书籍。
The librarians were told to move quickly, and they didn't use musty, or any sort of comparable system. The librarians were ordered to go through each collection book by book, and insert a slip of paper into each. Green, yellow, and red. Green meant the book had been checked out that year. Yellow meant the book had been checked out in the last two years, and red meant that it had been over two years since somebody had checked out that book. And the red books were the ones that were in potential danger. Danger because management had decided that the red books had to go. Compared to the careful consideration of musty, the system of the green, yellow,
馆员们被要求迅速行动，他们没有使用MUSTY或任何类似的系统。馆员们被命令逐本检查每一本藏书，并在每本书中插入一张纸条。绿色、黄色和红色。绿色意味着这本书当年被借阅过。黄色意味着这本书在过去两年内被借阅过，红色意味着这本书已经超过两年没有人借阅了。而红色标签的书就是那些处于潜在危险中的书。危险是因为管理层决定必须处理掉这些红标书。与MUSTY的仔细考量相比，这种绿、黄、
and red cards is a rather blunt instrument. It's certainly not the only measure whether somebody has borrowed it within the last period of time. It felt rather arbitrary. And it wasn't really clear where the red card books were going to go, or if they would ever be used again. In Jason Gibbs's department, for example, the art and music collection, the discarded books got sent to an abandoned hospital owned by the city, because there was nowhere else to put them. Even battle-hardened librarians, like Gibbs, felt that the weeding was happening too
红卡系统是一种相当粗暴的工具。这当然不是衡量某人是否在最近一段时间内借阅过的唯一标准。它感觉相当武断。而且并不清楚这些红卡书要去向何处，或者它们是否还会被再次使用。例如，在杰森·吉布斯的部门——艺术与音乐收藏部，被丢弃的书籍被送往了一家由市政府拥有的废弃医院，因为没有其他地方可以放它们。即使是像吉布斯这样久经沙场的馆员，也觉得剔旧进行得太
fast. You had librarians in different sections weeding furiously and not really communicating with each other. As a consequence, lots and lots of books were removed from the library. And no one quite knew how many, because no one was keeping track. It was ultimately, I think, a weakness of management from the top. Jason Gibbs is a pretty even-killed guy, but that's his diplomatic way of saying that the problems began with the head librarian at that time. A man named Kenneth Dowlin.
快了。“不同部门的馆员在疯狂地剔旧，彼此之间并没有真正的沟通。”结果，大量书籍被从图书馆移除。没有人确切知道有多少，因为没人进行记录。我认为这最终是管理层从上而下的软弱。杰森·吉布斯是一个相当冷静的人，但这只是他委婉的说法，意指问题始于当时的图书馆馆长，一个名叫肯尼斯·道林的男人。
Within a year or two, you could be visiting the public library. Without leaving your home since this is now. In the years leading up to the 1989 earthquake, the San Francisco Public Library was starting to rethink its whole approach to books, and light of a new little thing called the Internet. Imagine plugging a computer like this one into any telephone in the world and being able to search any library in the world. And a big part of this pivot was when, in 1987, San Francisco hired Kenneth Dowlin as its new city librarian.
“一两年内，你就可以在家访问公共图书馆了，因为现在是……”在1989年地震前的几年里，旧金山公共图书馆开始重新思考其处理书籍的整体方式，鉴于一种名为“互联网”的新事物。想象一下，把像这样的电脑插入世界上的任何电话，就能搜索世界上的任何图书馆。而这一转变的重要部分是，1987年，旧金山聘请了肯尼斯·道林担任新的城市图书馆馆长。
As San Francisco's city librarian, Ken Dowlin must make sure that two million people have access to 18 million books and other information on a limited budget. Dowlin was all about the internet. He had recently published a book called The Electronic Library, in which he argued that technology was changing the way people used information, and therefore changing the role of librarians. This is a clip of it. The internet web world, if you will, collapses time collapse this distance, and is collapsing cost.
作为旧金山市的图书馆馆长，肯·道林必须确保两百万人能在有限的预算内获取1800万册图书和其他信息。道林全心全意拥抱互联网。他最近出版了一本名为《电子图书馆》的书，书中他认为技术正在改变人们使用信息的方式，从而改变了图书馆员的角色。这是一段剪辑。“互联网，或者说网络世界，压缩了时间，压缩了距离，并且正在降低成本。”
If this sounds unremarkable, not to mention, a bit quaint, keep in mind that Dalin was saying all this stuff as early as 1984. He certainly understood at an early stage what the internet was going to do for communication. But there was a flipside to Dalin's visionary concept of digitally networked libraries. Some people felt that Dowlin had a distressing lack of concern for books. There was a sense that when it came to the physical collections, he just didn't have any interest. Dowlin was also overseeing the design of a new main library for the city of San Francisco,
如果这听起来平淡无奇，甚至有点古怪，请记住道林早在1984年就说了这些话。他确实在早期就理解了互联网将为通信带来什么。但道林对数字化联网图书馆的远见卓识也有另一面。有些人觉得道林对书籍有一种令人不安的漠视。有一种感觉是，当涉及到实体馆藏时，他根本没有任何兴趣。道林当时还在监督旧金山市新总馆的设计，
which would complete his vision of the library of the future. The city is building a new $100 million library that is wired for computers as well as television. This new library would have twice as much space as the old one, but a big chunk of that space wasn't going to be for shelving books. Instead, much of the library's interior was devoted to an atrium in the middle of the building, which would rise 86 feet to a conical glass roof. Lots of librarians worried that this big empty atrium wouldn't leave a lot of space
这将完成他对未来图书馆的愿景。“这座城市正在建造一座耗资1亿美元的新图书馆，它不仅连接了电脑，还连接了电视。”这座新图书馆的空间将是旧馆的两倍，但其中很大一部分空间将不会用于存放书籍。相反，图书馆内部的大部分空间被用于建筑中央的一个中庭，它将上升86英尺，通向一个圆锥形的玻璃屋顶。许多馆员担心这个巨大的空旷中庭不会留下太多空间
for books. The atrium was evidence that books were not the sole priority of this building, and Dallin wasn't going to let a good crisis go to waste. Earthquake was a perfect excuse to do what he wanted to do anyway. Shrink the physical collection before the move to the new space. Dowlands administration started sending books to landfills. In the days after the quake, books are being sent out by the truckload, several times a week.
给书籍。中庭证明了书籍并不是这座建筑的唯一优先事项，而道林不会浪费一场好危机。地震是一个完美的借口，让他去做他无论如何都想做的事：在搬迁到新空间之前缩减实体馆藏。道林的行政部门开始将书籍送往垃圾填埋场。地震后的几天里，书籍每周几次被卡车成批运走。
This is not normal library practice. 27 librarians signed a petition asking Kenneth Dowallin for the weeding to stop but that didn't work so Jason Gibbs and his colleagues decided to do something. In any institution you have a variety of people there are some people who will just kind of do whatever they're told and then there are other people who feel like they have a higher calling to the profession. Gibbs and librarians from several other departments felt that higher calling. They banded together and called themselves
这不是正常的图书馆做法。27名馆员签署了一份请愿书，要求肯尼斯·道林停止剔旧，但这没有奏效，所以杰森·吉布斯和他的同事们决定采取行动。在任何机构里，你都有各种各样的人，有些人只会听命行事，而另一些人则觉得他们对职业有一种更高的使命感。吉布斯和其他几个部门的馆员感受到了那种更高的使命感。他们联合起来，自称为
the Gorilla librarians. Gorilla like the freedom fighter. Fighting for the Freedom 2.0 put little slips of red paper on books against the orders of management. Let's just say that we did not withdraw books because they hadn't circulated. We generally held on to the collection. Jason says that other guerrilla librarians snuck into the stacks and replaced red slips
“游击队馆员”（Gorilla librarians）。游击队就像自由战士。为了“自由2.0”而战，违抗管理层的命令，在书上贴上红色小纸条。“我们只是说，我们不会因为书没有流通就撤架。我们通常会保留这些藏书。”杰森说，其他游击队馆员潜入书库，用绿色纸条替换了红色纸条，
with green ones, thereby designating the book as a circulating book and keeping it in the collection. The guerrilla librarians wanted to determine exactly how many books had been weeded and how many had been dumped, but nobody had any idea how many books were being taken away. And there was a risk that they'd never be able to find out the magnitude of this massive clearing. Because Kenneth Dallin decided to get rid of the physical card catalog, those files full of index cards chronically in each book.
从而将这些书指定为流通书籍，并将其保留在馆藏中。游击队馆员想确定到底有多少书被剔除，有多少书被倾倒，但没人知道有多少书被带走了。而且存在一种风险，他们可能永远无法发现这次大规模清理的规模。因为肯尼斯·道林决定处理掉实体卡片目录，那些记录每本书的索引卡片柜。
The card catalog is an artifact, an artifact, but I will not support the views of the card index cards, chronically in each book. He was right about this. Already at that point, more than 90% of the nation's libraries had computerized their card catalogs. The earthquake itself allowed the San Francisco Public Library to modernize their catalog. With a disaster relief money they were granted, the library was able to get electronic catalog software. So now, logically, Dalin wanted to get rid of the physical card catalog,
“卡片目录是一件文物，一件文物，但我不会支持卡片索引的观点……”他是对的。当时，全国90%以上的图书馆已经将卡片目录计算机化了。地震本身让旧金山公共图书馆得以实现目录现代化。利用获得的救灾资金，图书馆得以购买电子目录软件。所以现在，从逻辑上讲，道林想要处理掉实体卡片目录，
which the library had stopped updating in 1991. San Francisco's old card catalog was not moved to the new library. It is locked up and inaccessible to the public. But this move to get rid of the old card catalog caused a surprisingly intense outcry from the guerrilla librarians, and it wasn't just a matter of nostalgia or personal preference. The physical card catalog said exactly what was in the library before all the arbitrary weeding. If a book was red tagged and weeded, it wouldn't be registered in the New Digital System. There would be no record it had ever existed at all.
图书馆在1991年就停止了对该目录的更新。旧金山的旧卡片目录没有被搬到新图书馆。它被锁起来，公众无法访问。但这种处理旧卡片目录的举动引起了游击队馆员们出人意料的强烈抗议，这不仅仅是怀旧或个人偏好的问题。实体卡片目录准确记录了在所有武断的剔旧之前，图书馆里有什么。如果一本书被贴上红标并被剔除，它就不会在新的数字系统中注册。将没有任何记录表明它曾经存在过。
And so the old card catalog was more than just a card catalog. The card catalog is evidence. Evidence of a purge. To get to the card catalog, the librarians pulled out their secret weapon, Nicholson Baker. I'm Nicholson Baker and I am a writer of books, fiction, nonfiction, and I became for a brief period of time a library activist. Baker is a writer of novels and essays that celebrate the minutia of daily life. And in 1994, Baker had gotten national attention for a New Yorker article about the disposal
所以旧卡片目录不仅仅是卡片目录。卡片目录是证据。清洗的证据。为了接触到卡片目录，馆员们拿出了他们的秘密武器：尼科尔森·贝克。“我是尼科尔森·贝克，我是小说、非虚构类书籍的作者，我曾短暂地成为了一名图书馆活动家。”贝克是一位创作小说和散文的作家，赞美日常生活中的琐碎细节。1994年，贝克因一篇关于处理
of physical card catalogs. A practice that had become increasingly common, in which upset Baker a lot. The San Francisco Public Library had a very ornate, beautiful card catalog. That feeling that you have when your fingers would dance over the little cardboard pieces and you could tell a subject that was popular because the tops were darker and there's all sorts of you know tricks that were just fun. The Guerrilla librarians reached out to Baker for help. By now it was 1996 and the new library was nearing completion. The lost books, evidenced only by their locked-away card catalog, were teetering on the edge of disregard.
实体卡片目录的《纽约客》文章而受到全国关注。这种做法变得越来越普遍，这让贝克非常不安。“旧金山公共图书馆有一个非常华丽、漂亮的卡片目录。那种感觉，当你的手指在小纸板上跳动时，你可以分辨出哪些主题很受欢迎，因为顶部颜色更深，还有各种各样的小技巧，真的很有趣。”游击队馆员向贝克寻求帮助。到1996年，新图书馆即将完工。那些丢失的书籍，只有锁起来的卡片目录作为证据，正处于被遗忘的边缘。
In their email to Nicholson Baker, the librarians wrote, you're the only one who can save it now. Part of me thought, oh God, this is going to get complicated. Oh, it would. At the time, Baker was living just across the Bay in Berkeley, so he made a formal request to inspect the card catalog. Kenneth Dallin denied that request. So Baker sued the library for access to the card catalog.
在给尼科尔森·贝克的电子邮件中，馆员们写道：“现在只有你能拯救它了。”我心里想，天哪，这会变得很复杂。确实如此。当时，贝克住在海湾对岸的伯克利，所以他正式提出请求，要求检查卡片目录。肯尼斯·道林拒绝了该请求。于是贝克起诉图书馆，要求获得访问卡片目录的权利。
Never sue anything if you can avoid it and don't sue a library. This lawsuit took a while, and it was a bit of a mess, but it automatically classified the card catalog as a public document. Now the library had to keep it. And then Baker and the guerrilla librarians got to work in secret. And you know, you can imagine this with kind of mission and possible music going.
“如果能避免，永远不要起诉任何东西，也不要起诉图书馆。”这场诉讼持续了一段时间，有点混乱，但它自动将卡片目录归类为公共文件。现在图书馆必须保留它。然后贝克和游击队馆员们秘密行动起来。“你可以想象一下，伴随着某种《碟中谍》式的音乐。”
Yes, please. The guerrilla librarians snuck into off limits areas in the library. They took away books that were going to be destroyed. In other words, they stole them. The Gorilla's stockpiled hundreds and hundreds of library discards in their homes, in their cars, in their offices, and lockers, and boxes all in the hope that they would someday be returned to the library.
“是的，请。”游击队馆员潜入图书馆的禁区。他们带走了那些即将被销毁的书。换句话说，他们偷了它们。游击队在家里、车里、办公室、储物柜和盒子里囤积了数百本图书馆丢弃的书籍，所有这些都是为了希望有一天它们能被归还给图书馆。
Nichols and Baker stole books, too. I was driving back and forth across the bay bridge with my car full of books that I had actually found in this place that was the deselection room. Baker ignored the staff only signs and walked right into the deselection room, the basement storage, all the places where the SFPL were storing books.
尼科尔森·贝克也偷了书。“我开车往返于海湾大桥，车里装满了我在那个被称为‘筛选室’的地方发现的书。”贝克无视“员工专用”的标志，直接走进筛选室、地下室仓库，以及旧金山公共图书馆存放书籍的所有地方。
He picked up a bunch of books that had no match in the online catalog and found some real treasures. They had stored all these, you know, including 17th century, very valuable books and stuff was down there. Baker, along with the historian, began comparing the online catalog to the physical card catalog. As they cross-referenced the two lists, it turned out that a lot of books were missing. Way more than anyone had expected. Let me tell you what an opening day celebration today. At last, in April of 1996, the new main library opened its doors with Penache.
他捡起了一堆在在线目录中找不到匹配项的书，并发现了一些真正的宝藏。“他们把所有这些都存放在那里，包括17世纪非常有价值的书籍等等。”贝克与一位历史学家开始将在线目录与实体卡片目录进行对比。当他们交叉核对这两个列表时，结果发现很多书不见了。比任何人预期的都要多。“让我告诉你，今天的开幕日庆祝活动是多么盛大。”终于，在1996年4月，新总馆盛大开幕。
Talk about fanfare. Nothing less than a parachute jump into Civic Center with the man holding the symbolic key to the new library. And in May of 1996, about a month after the library opened, the guerrilla librarians organized an event in the library auditorium, where Baker delivered a speech stating what he had found. Baker contended that Dallin was responsible for a massive destruction of books, The systematic removal to a landfill of at least 200,000 volumes. And I just said it right there in the library itself. In a talk, and I think it really startled people. The phrase that got Baker the most attention
谈谈盛况。简直就是跳伞降落到市政中心，那个人手里拿着新图书馆的象征性钥匙。1996年5月，也就是图书馆开馆一个月后，游击队馆员在图书馆礼堂组织了一场活动，贝克发表了演讲，陈述了他的发现。贝克主张道林应对大规模销毁书籍负责，即系统性地将至少20万册书籍运往垃圾填埋场。“我就在图书馆里直接说了出来。在一次演讲中，我想这真的让人们感到震惊。”让贝克获得最多关注的短语
was when he called this mass disposal, a quote, hate crime directed at the past. This really upset library management. And it became this kind of minor dust up in San Francisco. Word had begun to spread that Baker was writing another story for The New Yorker, one specifically about this whole weeding debacle. So the president of the Library Commission
是他称这种大规模处理为“针对过去的仇恨犯罪”。这让图书馆管理层非常不安。这在旧金山演变成了一场小规模的冲突。有传言说贝克正在为《纽约客》写另一篇报道，专门关于整个剔旧惨败。所以图书馆委员会主席
wrote to The New Yorker's editor at that time and attempted to kill the piece by discrediting Baker. It didn't work and Baker's article came out in October of 1996. It was called The Author Versus the Library. A current New Yorker article called it the Great Book Purge, claiming more than 100,000 rare and one of a kind books were hauled to the dump. And then things got a little out of hand. The library hit back, condemning Baker for accusing them of a hate crime, and saying that he misunderstood the problem. They also tried to discredit him because of some bad math he had reported.
写信给当时的《纽约客》编辑，试图通过抹黑贝克来扼杀这篇文章。这没奏效，贝克的文章于1996年10月发表。文章标题为《作者对阵图书馆》。一篇当前的《纽约客》文章称其为“大书清洗”，声称超过10万本珍稀和孤本图书被运往垃圾场。然后事情有点失控了。图书馆反击，谴责贝克指控他们犯有仇恨犯罪，并称他误解了问题。他们还试图因为他报告的一些错误数据来抹黑他。
It turns out one of the grill librarians had messed up the measurements of the old library shelves. In fact, the new library had much more space for books than the old one. It was a very bad era. It was very embarrassing. Although it didn't change the fact that the library had taken so many books to the dump, then both sides started lobbying insults at each other as the local and national press piled on. One paper compared Baker to the Unibummer, it was basically an in-log Twitter feud.
事实证明，其中一名游击队馆员弄错了旧图书馆书架的测量数据。事实上，新图书馆的书架空间比旧馆多得多。“那是一个非常糟糕的时代。非常尴尬。”尽管这并没有改变图书馆将这么多书运往垃圾场的事实，然后双方开始互相辱骂，当地和全国媒体也纷纷加入。一家报纸将贝克比作“大学炸弹客”，这基本上就是一场线下版的推特骂战。
I wasn't prepared to be part of it. I didn't know that I was getting into that, kind of a battle. It was really ugly. And even from Guerrilla Library and Jason Gibbs' standpoint, the whole weeding controversy got a little blown out of proportion. It probably was not as horrible as Nicholson Baker made it out, but it was horrible enough. Meanwhile, the new library itself had already been built, and it was, judging from the influx of visitors, a success. As charges and countercharges fly, three times as many visitors stream through the
“我没准备好参与其中。我不知道我卷入了那种战斗。真的很丑陋。”即使从游击队馆员杰森·吉布斯的角度来看，整个剔旧争议也有点被夸大了。它可能不像尼科尔森·贝克描述的那样可怕，但已经足够可怕了。与此同时，新图书馆本身已经建成，从涌入的游客来看，它很成功。随着指控和反指控满天飞，三倍多的游客涌入
doors of the new library, an indication that some book lovers welcome the change. and indication that some book lovers welcome the change. Some of those books saved by the guerrilla librarians and boxes and lockers were transferred back into the collection. All the books in Jason Gibbs' department, Heart and Music, made it back. But he says that many of the other books didn't. They stayed gone, and many of them probably got discarded. Nicholson Baker says he still has some of the books he stockpiled. Given the painful experience of the controversy, the library wasn't really interested in reshelfing
新图书馆的大门，这表明一些书迷欢迎这种变化。一些被游击队馆员保存在盒子和储物柜里的书被转回了馆藏。杰森·吉布斯部门（艺术与音乐部）的所有书籍都回来了。但他说，许多其他书籍没有回来。它们消失了，其中许多可能被丢弃了。尼科尔森·贝克说他仍然保留着一些他囤积的书。鉴于争议带来的痛苦经历，图书馆对重新上架
them. But I think to the day, the controversy wasn't only about what to do with old books. It was a debate about what books are. Are they beautiful objects that we can smell and touch and collect? Or are they eternal sources of knowledge accessible to everyone in the ether? Well, and it's both. In a given research quest, you and I might want to find out what is in a book in the fastest possible way. Well, nowadays it's miraculous. Sometimes you want the words. Sometimes you want more than the words you want. The words laid out on the page.
它们并不感兴趣。但我认为，直到今天，这场争议不仅仅是关于如何处理旧书。这是一场关于书是什么的辩论。它们是我们能闻、能摸、能收藏的美丽物品吗？还是它们是存在于以太中、每个人都能获取的永恒知识源泉？嗯，两者都是。在特定的研究任务中，你和我可能都想以最快的方式找出书里的内容。嗯，如今这简直是奇迹。有时你想要文字。有时你想要的不仅仅是文字，你想要文字在页面上的排版。
Clearly, Nicholson Baker can see Dowlands' perspective. But Baker maintains that we shouldn't give up on the printed page. His argument, and the public battle around it in the 90s, was a big reason why the San Francisco Public Library totally overhauled their collections policies. They made it a policy, but if a library branch is considering weeding a last copy of some book, they must send that copy to a subject specialist who will decide if it can be weeded or not. And for the books that do have to go, the San Francisco Public Library developed a community redistribution program to make sure the extra copies of popular books can live on somewhere else. We distribute them to schools and city colleges and prisons.
显然，尼科尔森·贝克能理解道林的观点。但贝克坚持认为我们不应该放弃纸质书。他的论点以及90年代围绕它的公开斗争，是旧金山公共图书馆彻底改革其馆藏政策的一个重要原因。他们制定了一项政策：如果图书馆分馆考虑剔除某本书的最后一个副本，他们必须将其发送给主题专家，由专家决定是否可以剔除。对于那些确实需要处理的书籍，旧金山公共图书馆开发了一个社区再分配计划，以确保流行书籍的额外副本可以在其他地方继续存在。“我们将它们分发给学校、城市学院和监狱。”
And strangely enough, one of the biggest changes to the modern practice of weeding is something that Kenneth Dalin himself helped establish. Online communication between libraries. You know, in an ideal world, you might want to have every book, but we just don't have the shelf space for every book, so you rely on somebody else's shelves to have every book, but we just don't have the shelf space for every book, so you rely on somebody else's shelves to hold the book. Some libraries spell musty with an eye and an e at the end, instead of a y, for misleading, ugly, superseded, trivial, irrelevant, or elsewhere, like if a copy of the book is at another
奇怪的是，现代剔旧做法的最大变化之一是肯尼斯·道林本人帮助建立的东西：图书馆之间的在线交流。“你知道，在理想的世界里，你可能想拥有每一本书，但我们就是没有足够的书架空间来存放每一本书，所以你依赖别人的书架来存放书籍。”有些图书馆将MUSTY拼写为MUSTIE，用I和E结尾，而不是Y，代表误导、丑陋、被取代、琐碎、无关，或者“其他地方”（Elsewhere），比如如果这本书的副本在附近另一个
library nearby. Jason Gibbs at the SFPL and Sharon McHeller across the Bay at the Oakland Public Library can now communicate with each other instantly so they can share book space and make different volumes available to readers in both cities. And this has huge implications
图书馆里。旧金山公共图书馆的杰森·吉布斯和海湾对岸奥克兰公共图书馆的莎伦·麦凯勒现在可以即时交流，这样他们就可以共享图书空间，并让两座城市的读者都能获得不同的卷册。这对
for what gets weeded and why. In this respect, Kenneth Dallin was very right. He certainly failed in terms of managing the collection, but he succeeded to the extent of bringing us into the wider network of libraries online. And yet still, because of Baker's 1996 lawsuit, the San Francisco Public Library has kept the old card catalog. They are legally required to. The card catalog was a way of holding on onto the memory of a quarter of a million books
什么会被剔除以及原因产生了巨大的影响。在这方面，肯尼斯·道林是非常正确的。他在管理馆藏方面确实失败了，但在将我们带入更广泛的在线图书馆网络方面，他成功了。然而，由于贝克1996年的诉讼，旧金山公共图书馆保留了旧卡片目录。他们法律上必须这样做。卡片目录是一种保留四分之一百万本书记忆的方式，
that they'd gotten rid of. Those cabinets full of cards are still there in storage. Practically barricaded by all kinds of other supplies, but I'll go down and visit every now and then. Just to say hi? Yeah, we'll just just to know what's there. After this weeding debacle, Nicholson Baker became even more vested in philosophies and practices of archiving, and went along to publish a book that touched on all this, called Double Fold. It looks at these events in the much broader context of the digitization of libraries, and this book is now commonly assigned in master's programs in library science. We read the Nicholson Baker book in library school.
那些被他们处理掉的书。那些装满卡片的柜子仍然存放在仓库里。实际上被各种其他物资封锁了，但我偶尔会下去看看。“只是去打个招呼？”“是的，只是为了知道它们还在那里。”在这次剔旧惨败之后，尼科尔森·贝克对归档的哲学和实践变得更加投入，并出版了一本涉及所有这些内容的书，名为《双重折叠》（Double Fold）。它在图书馆数字化这一更广泛的背景下审视了这些事件，这本书现在通常被图书馆学硕士课程指定为必读书目。“我们在图书馆学校读过尼科尔森·贝克的书。”
That's Sharon McKellar again from the Oakland Public Library. She says that the debacle at the San Francisco Public Library has become a case study about weeding. Why we do weeding and how we should weed and what could be done, you know, how to do it well and what to avoid and all that kind of stuff. And when it's done well with care and consideration, weeding isn't so bad at all. For me weeding is fun. It's a chance to really touch the books and see how they're doing and see what people
那是奥克兰公共图书馆的莎伦·麦凯勒。她说，旧金山公共图书馆的惨败已经成为关于剔旧的案例研究。为什么我们要剔旧，我们应该如何剔旧，以及可以做些什么，你知道，如何做好它，以及要避免什么等等。当它做得好、充满关怀和考量时，剔旧一点也不坏。“对我来说，剔旧很有趣。这是一个真正触摸书籍、看看它们状况如何、看看人们
are interested in. That's what all this comes down to. It's what people are interested in. Weeding isn't just about what to cut. It's also about what to keep. It's about what the public wants to read. Your voice does matter and we're maintaining a collection for the public and for the people who use it.
对什么感兴趣的机会。”这就是这一切的归结所在。这就是人们感兴趣的东西。剔旧不仅仅是关于删减什么。它也关于保留什么。它关于公众想读什么。你的声音确实很重要，我们正在为公众和使用它的人维护一个馆藏。
And so every time you check out a book from the library, you are casting a vote to your local librarian, Roving the Stacks, to keep this title in circulation for everyone to read. Coming up, more radical librarians doing good in the world. This time, on Horseback, after this. The kitchen sisters are Davia Nelson and Nikki Silva, two audio documentary pine ears who are like the godmothers of the radio topia collective. You can hear their stories regularly on NPR and we're lucky to have their podcast called the Kitchen Sisters Presents on radio topia. The current series they're working on is called The Keepers.
所以每次你从图书馆借出一本书，你都在向你的当地馆员投出一票，让他们把这本书保留在流通中，供所有人阅读。接下来，更多在世界上做好事的激进图书馆员。这次是在马背上，稍后回来。“厨房姐妹”（The Kitchen Sisters）是达维亚·尼尔森和尼基·席尔瓦，两位音频纪录片先驱，她们就像RadioTopia集体的教母。你可以定期在NPR上听到她们的故事，我们很幸运能在RadioTopia上拥有她们的播客《厨房姐妹呈现》（The Kitchen Sisters Presents）。她们目前正在制作的系列节目叫《守护者》（The Keepers）。
It's all about the guardians of history, the eccentric individuals who take it upon themselves to protect the free flow of information and preserve some part of our cultural heritage. And when we were producing our story this week about the preservation of the SFPL's book collections, I thought a lot about the Kitchen Sisters Keeper series and this story in particular, and I wanted to share it with you. This episode is called The Pack Horse Librarians of Eastern Kentucky. My name is Mary Ruth Schuder, leader, I'm 97 years old. We travel on the horses riding down in the mountains of Kentucky, very poor country. I was delivering books to the children. They were stubborn. It was one of the works of Post-It Rose.
它讲述的是历史的守护者，那些自发保护信息自由流动并保存我们部分文化遗产的古怪个人。当我们本周制作关于保存旧金山公共图书馆馆藏的故事时，我经常想到“厨房姐妹”的《守护者》系列，特别是这个故事，我想与你们分享。这一集名为《肯塔基州东部的马背图书馆员》。我是玛丽·露丝·舒德，领队，我97岁了。我们骑着马在肯塔基州的山区穿行，那是很贫穷的地方。我当时在给孩子们送书。他们很固执。那是罗斯（Post-It Rose）的作品之一。
That's Ruth, one of the last of the Pack Horse librarians. Today, episode two in the Keepers series, stories of activist archivists, rogue librarians, curators, collectors, and historians, the kitchen sisters present the pack-horse librarians of Eastern Kentucky. Our problem is to put to work three and one half million and probably the first men and women,
那是露丝，最后一位马背图书馆员之一。今天，是《守护者》系列的第二集，讲述激进档案管理员、流氓图书馆员、策展人、收藏家和历史学家的故事，“厨房姐妹”呈现《肯塔基州东部的马背图书馆员》。“我们的问题是让三百五十万人投入工作，可能是第一批男女，
one now on the relief road. In the depression, those horrible years after 1929, the Appalachians were hit so hard, coal mines were being shut down, lots of people in dire poverty. Eleanor Roosevelt decided to help create projects that would specifically benefit women and children. My name is Heather Henson, author of that book, Women, Eleanor Roosevelt, felt very strongly about the Pack Horse Library Project. If the women are willing to do this, of course it's going to help them, neighbor. I think we'll win out. The Pack Horse Librarians, mostly women, rode circuits. Round 18 to 20 miles, they followed animal paths, fence lines. I'm Kathy Appell. I co-wrote downcouching creek, the Pack Horse Librarians of Kentucky. They would stuff their saddlebags or a pillowcase with books and strike out by horsebacker
现在在救济道路上。”在大萧条时期，1929年之后那些可怕的岁月里，阿巴拉契亚地区受到了重创，煤矿关闭，许多人陷入极度贫困。埃莉诺·罗斯福决定帮助创建专门造福妇女和儿童的项目。“我是希瑟·亨森，那本书的作者，埃莉诺·罗斯福非常支持马背图书馆项目。如果妇女们愿意这样做，当然这会帮助她们，邻居。我想我们会赢的。”马背图书馆员大多是女性，她们骑马巡回。“绕行18到20英里，她们沿着动物路径、围栏线走。我是凯西·阿佩尔。我合著了《DownCouching Creek》，讲述肯塔基州的马背图书馆员。”她们会把书塞进马鞍袋或枕套里，骑着马或
mule to provide library service to the remote areas of the Kentucky mountains going into the Appalachian Mountains of Kentucky was going back in time. No running water, no electricity, very few schools. Families live way up in the mountains. A creek bed, that would be the road. We forwarded crazy creek, take the torches across, got ready with, way up to your. You don't get afraid. You do your job and that was it. You had to be hearty. Being able to clamber up the side of a mountain on a horse, you had to know the roads and creek beds. My name is Eliza McGraw. I wrote a story about the Pack Horse Librarians for the Smithsonian. One county would start a
骡子出发，为肯塔基山区偏远地区提供图书馆服务。进入肯塔基州的阿巴拉契亚山脉就像回到了过去。没有自来水，没有电，学校很少。家庭住在深山里。溪床就是道路。“我们涉过疯狂的溪流，带着火把过河，准备好，水深及腰。你不会害怕。你做你的工作，就是这样。”你必须坚强。能够骑马爬上山坡，你必须熟悉道路和溪床。“我是伊丽莎·麦格劳。我为史密森尼学会写了一个关于马背图书馆员的故事。”一个县会开始一个
Pack Horse Library. Another county would hear about it. They would want one. Then that community would ask the WPA to let them hire carriers. Many of them were women between 25 and 35. There weren't people coming in from outside to take jobs from people who were in the community. They were local women familiar with and the people who wanted to read and what they might want to read. My grandmother, she was a horseback librarian.
马背图书馆。另一个县听说后，也会想要一个。然后那个社区会要求WPA让他们雇佣搬运工。她们中的许多人是25到35岁的女性。没有外来人员来抢走社区里人们的工作。她们是当地女性，熟悉那些想读书的人，以及他们可能想读什么。我的祖母，她就是一位马背图书馆员。
She was involved with the WPA because that was the workforce of the time. Because Eastern Kentucky you either worked or you starved a death. I'm Rick Overby, grandson of Grace Cautill Lucas. She would ride that horse, carriage trails, mudholes, or going back up into these haulers. She didn't own the horse. She rented it for 50 cents a week. She would arrange the books and a pack that would ride behind her on the saddle She would haul around up to a hundred and not only books but magazines of the time and newspaper Grace was a young mother with two small children her husband Left in the depression a lot of men did that
她参与了WPA（公共事业振兴署），因为那是当时的主要劳动力来源。在肯塔基州东部，你要么工作，要么饿死。我是里克·奥弗比，格蕾丝·考蒂尔·卢卡斯的孙子。她会骑着马，穿过马车道、泥坑，或者回到那些偏僻的山谷里。马不是她自己的，她每周花50美分租用。她会把书整理好，放在马鞍后的包里。她一次最多能运送一百本书，不仅有书，还有当时的杂志和报纸。格蕾丝是一位年轻的母亲，有两个年幼的孩子，她的丈夫在大萧条时期离开了，很多男人都那样做了。
I finally left home when I was two and my sister was about to my old name's Richard over me and on the son of Grace Carl Lucas, my mother, where she'd get up every morning about 430. Feed me and my sister and take us to my grandma grandma until she got home at night. Then she would feed us and put us to bed and start all over the next day. Dollar a day. She was glad to have it. She bought groceries and things that we'd never had before.
我两岁时，我母亲终于离开了家，我姐姐也快要……我原来的名字叫理查德·奥弗比，是格蕾丝·卡尔·卢卡斯的孙子。我母亲每天早上4点半起床，喂我和姐姐，然后把我们送到我奶奶家，直到她晚上回家。然后她会喂我们吃饭，哄我们睡觉，第二天又重新开始。每天一美元。她很庆幸能有这份工作。她买了我们以前从未有过的杂货和东西。
The only thing the federal government provided was the salary for the carriers. My name is Jean Schmitzer, co-author, down-cut Shin Creek, Path Course Library of Eastern Kentucky. Leighna Noff's here, one of the leaders in the Kentucky Library Association, really goes to bat for this project. She started something called the Penny Fund. It asked for all of the state parent-teacher associations to donate a penny. Children donated pennies, one little school collected enough pennies to make a dollar and they sent the dollar in.
联邦政府提供的唯一东西就是送书员的工资。我叫简·施米策，是《肯塔基州东部驮马图书馆》的合著者。肯塔基州图书馆协会的领导人之一莱娜·诺夫斯在这里，她真的为这个项目竭尽全力。她发起了一个叫“便士基金”的项目，要求全州所有的家长教师协会捐出一便士。孩子们捐出了便士，有一所小学校收集的便士凑够了一美元，他们就把这一美元寄了过来。
This being the depression, it was hard for people to give up anything. I mean, even a penny drive was taxing. As people from all over the United States learned about this, they would donate cast-off magazines, used books, Swiss family Robinson, Heidi. Better Homes and Gardens, National Geographic, Popular Mechanics. By 1937, they'd gotten 60,000 books. The librarians would go through these ragged magazines and dilapidated books, and they would cannibalize them, deconstruct them, remix them, and create these new scrapbooks.
在大萧条时期，人们很难放弃任何东西。我的意思是，即使是便士募捐也是一种负担。当美国各地的人们了解到这件事后，他们会捐出废弃的杂志、旧书，比如《瑞士家庭鲁滨逊》、《海蒂》、《美好家园》、《国家地理》、《大众机械》。到1937年，他们已经收集了6万本书。图书管理员会翻阅这些破旧的杂志和残破的书籍，将它们拆解、重组，制作成新的剪贴簿。
I'm Jason Vance, librarian, middle Tennessee State University. Library Manual for WPA Pack Horse Library Projects. The following scrapbooks have been found useful. Recipes, mountain ballads, Kentucky history, odd names, articles on a particular subject, dogs, spain, Nazis, model airplanes. Carriers would collect recipes and patterns for quilts from people on the round. Put them together into a scrapbook and share county to county. In 1940, there were 2,582 of these scrapbooks. They became part of the circulating collection.
我是杰森·万斯，中田纳西州立大学的图书管理员。《WPA驮马图书馆项目手册》中提到，以下剪贴簿被证明很有用：食谱、山地民谣、肯塔基历史、奇怪的名字、特定主题的文章、狗、西班牙、纳粹、模型飞机。送书员会收集沿途人们的食谱和拼布图案，把它们整理成剪贴簿，并在各县之间传阅。1940年，这类剪贴簿有2582本。它们成为了流通馆藏的一部分。
The Pack Horse librarians were creating these cultural artifacts, snapshots of life and Eastern Kentucky during the Great Depression. We were so happy to get a book, kick of the death. We always sat under the big old chestnut tree. They didn't know how to read. So I read it again so we could understand this. Kentucky in 1930, a literacy in those southeastern counties was anywhere from 19 to 31%.
驮马图书馆员们正在创造这些文化产物，记录下大萧条时期肯塔基州东部生活的快照。“我们能得到一本书真是太高兴了，简直乐坏了。我们总是坐在那棵老栗子树下。他们不知道怎么读书，所以我又读了一遍，这样我们就能理解了。”1930年，肯塔基州东南部各县的文盲率在19%到31%之间。
Some people were originally a little bit leery of the Pacthorse librarians because reading was seen as sort of a leisure activity. When you're trying to get this corn hood and work done on a small farm, somebody can't be sitting with their feet up reading. This was just frivolous. There was a lot of illiteracy there.
有些人最初对驮马图书馆员有点怀疑，因为阅读被视为一种休闲活动。当你试图在小农场里耕种和干活时，怎么能有人坐着休息看书呢？这简直是轻浮。那里有很多文盲。
The pack-horse librarians would sit and read to people at the houses, then mount back up and get going. They were really houffing it to get done before dark. Grace was out on a winter day and it started to sleep ice falling out of the sky. Normally she might have stopped at one of the households along the way and spent the night, but the last house on her circuit was a family that she knew if she stayed there, that they would feed her, and likely that would mean nothing for the kids.
驮马图书馆员会坐在人们家里读书，然后重新上马出发。为了在天黑前完成工作，她们真的在拼命赶路。格蕾丝在冬日里外出，天开始下起雨夹雪，冰块从天而降。通常她可能会在沿途的一户人家停下来过夜，但她路线上的最后一户人家，她知道如果她留在那儿，他们会给她食物，而那很可能意味着孩子们就没得吃了。
So, she just pushed on. Before she could get home, she had to cross a creek. The water was high enough, it covered her stirrups. By the time she got home, her feet were encased in ice. Grisha would ride that horse and he was going through the creeks. She had mountains to climb and feathers to go through. The program ended in 1943. We're in the war. We're pulling out of this depression. The library program was no longer funded by the federal government, the salaries for carriers.
所以，她只是继续前行。在到家之前，她必须穿过一条小溪。水很高，淹没了她的马镫。当她到家时，她的脚已经冻在冰里了。格蕾丝会骑着那匹马穿过小溪。她要翻山越岭，还要穿过羽毛般的雪地。该项目于1943年结束。我们正处于战争中，正在走出大萧条。图书馆项目不再由联邦政府资助送书员的工资。
But 1954, the state of Kentucky starts a bookmobile program. In Alaska, there are bush-plane librarians. In Africa, there's camel librarians. In Louisiana, there were floating librarians, pulling flatboats in the bios. In Thailand, they're using elephants. In Zimbabwe, they're using donkeys and Mongolia. They're using horse-drawn wagons.
但1954年，肯塔基州开始了流动图书馆项目。在阿拉斯加，有丛林飞机图书馆员；在非洲，有骆驼图书馆员；在路易斯安那州，有浮动图书馆员，在河口划着平底船；在泰国，他们使用大象；在津巴布韦，他们使用驴子；在蒙古，他们使用马车。
In our mind, we think of librarians as the quintessential Marion, the librarian. Somebody who puts the books back on the shelves, does, and makes sure that everything's tidy. Librarians are a determined bunch. They're far more subversive than that. The pack-horse librarians of Eastern Kentucky was produced by the kitchen sisters and mixed
在我们的印象中，我们认为图书管理员是典型的“玛丽安式”人物。那种把书放回书架、确保一切整洁的人。但图书管理员是一群意志坚定的人。她们远比那更具颠覆性。《肯塔基州东部的驮马图书馆员》由Kitchen Sisters制作，并由吉姆·麦基混音。
by Jim McKee. You can hear more from the Keepers series on their podcast, The Kitchen Sisters Present from Radio Topia. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Pierce Kelly and Edited by Avery Trophman, Mixing Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mousso, Vivian Lee, Sophia Kletzger, and me Roman Mars.
你可以在Radio Topia的播客《The Kitchen Sisters Present》中听到更多关于“守护者”系列的内容。《99% Invisible》本周由皮尔斯·凯利制作，艾弗里·特罗夫曼编辑，谢丽·福塞夫负责混音技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·穆索、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克莱茨格，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。
Ken Dallin did not respond to our various requests for an interview on the San Francisco Public Library story, but a very special thanks to all the librarians who helped on context and background, especially Shelley Cocking and Mindy Linesky, both from the San Francisco Public Library. Thanks as well to Orrin Rudowsky. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at
肯·达林没有回应我们关于旧金山公共图书馆故事的多次采访请求，但特别感谢所有在背景和资料方面提供帮助的图书管理员，特别是旧金山公共图书馆的雪莉·科金和明迪·莱内斯基。也感谢奥林·鲁多夫斯基。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的广播街制作。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注
Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But the full archive of all things 99% invisible is at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
罗曼·马尔斯和节目账号@99PI.org，或者在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注。关于《99% Invisible》的所有完整档案都在99PI.org。Radio Topia from PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。